j'ai bientôt sur des petits gueule et
c'est parti start
voilà très vite voir ce que c'est
morning ngor ont juste aucun policier
qui en fait se déplacent de manière
extrêmement bizarre suite à un accident
avec de la glu radioactive est un chat
voilà j'invente passé ce qui est marqué
dans la description du jeu et on doit
faire régner l'ordre dans cette ville
voilà et apparemment on lui veut qu'on a
mangé ses larmes de la banque
oui à temps mais c'est quoi ce braqueur
avec une banane quoi ta gueule on doit
la stopper va l'attraper d'un goal c'est
pas sûr va l'attraper
on n'a pas le temps elle est où aller au
léopard dont on va où il restait à ton
mail à 20,5 rennais lui attend mais je
fais demi tour dans cette poursuite pour
voir ce n'est quoi t'as pas mal pas mal
viala un voleur tu ne peux pas
m'échapper
finalement ça a plus vite de glisser par
terre que devront courir je peux
pratiquer un an mon dieu oh il a fait un
accident d'auto avec une banane et
disparaît comme on dit c'est quoi ce
voleur sans déconner nous devons
investiguer le crash en les pauvres
petits chats innocent il aurait pu être
tuée à mouler dans le camion avant qu'il
parte dans la rue donc on va devoir
aller dans cette colle pour ensuite
coller les chars allez venez pas ici lui
le choc direct
il nous a mal on regarde et je n'ai vu
en place assez fait mr extrêmement
simple d'attraper les chats les pompiers
font ça d'ailleurs comme à chaque fois
sans armes allez venez là n'hésitez pas
à n'ai pas peur homme je suis doux comme
vous je suis dit j'ai du pelage mossi
s'appelle des toiles voilà allez va
acheter de donald tsang au prêt tu viens
pas te toucher pendant que je commandais
do not what u 10 à moi j'aime bien
coller les gens [ __ ] mais c'est l'auto
du grenat mais lui je suis sûr qu'il
prépare un complot il prépare un plan
soit possible il espionne la police
comme ça pour ensuite mieux frapper sur
quoi on va tomber jeu attention au chien
ce chien dans sa niche
oh [ __ ] mais voir un énorme chien qui
va sortir yes le droit se laver dans la
douche rapide
c'est au ces sachets avec mais c'est pas
plutôt cher cette [ __ ] de chèvre de
m'enfuir dit non alors tu es des coupes
adobe le gotha c'est rien ça arrive
voilà mais je suis choqué par ses avants
bras quand on regarde il balaye le sol
gros poêle avec cet homme quoi écoutez
nous on remportait on est tout
maigrichons voilà bien fera devant
intervenir
django je te suis à toi un peu par
contre pas si simple de se déplacer un
public j'ai eu un terrible accident et
qui n'a rien d'amusant finalement vous
êtes un peu en scheiber a dû activer le
voleur passe par là le web webkit bol
puis par à pied comme ça tranquillement
un fantôme
mais l'atout tout parent steak là
impossible là y'a tout à la fois le
voleur le feu le fantôme
[Musique]
ah oui à elle possédait alors bien sûr
le toit et moi si tu peux fixé l'eau à
oui c'est vrai que je puisse qu'elle a
des bien sûr de manière très naturelle
comme dans la vie de tous les jours à
terme la tour eiffel c'est vous propose
l'escalier à l'ascenseur et l'escaladent
c'est vrai que la semana très
conventionnel vraiment d'aller aider son
prochain vous aussi allez dévouent pour
aller mon âme énorme et on balance des
trucs dessus sa femme possédée la hausse
et ça dans la guitare au piège aurait
pris en plein air je te fais un petit
air de jambo cet or est dépossédé des
monts à mais non mais déjà à droite vite
au hockey les honey est là à la fois l x
h
seul avantage est patent que je de la
guitare avec notre pied comme ça voilà
c'est bon nous sommes neutres sur le
toit regardez on voit cette femme
poussée qui disparaît ou effectivement
procédé à l'éval dans je peux pas en
fait mais qu'est-ce qui se passe j'ai un
break est bloqué dans le mur je suis
pendu du bras s'il vous plaît aidez moi
c'est cet endroit c'est normal à cause
du peuple à tout refaire [ __ ] mais
est-ce qu'on peut pas passer par
l'entrée sinon non c'est à cognac
passions se paye tout logique passer par
l'entrée nous sommes spider man spider
man qui fait un peu la gueule un peu a
dit qu les mais bon c'est pas mal quand
même
ojm et vomit dessus carrément nikki
saloperies démons si on devient roi à la
fin de ce jeu s'il est totalement
impossible je ferais pendre l'architecte
dessus mais vas-y assomme mois et aucun
problème je suis pas déjà sans
difficulté yes franchement j'aurais mis
moins de temps allait vraiment sur le
toit de mon immeuble actuellement 1 je
veux sauver la ville
non mais tu m'as qui a fait un bts ce
voleur de j'aimerais qu'une bande c'est
en plus une fesci bon travail merci
voleur mais non il a tout changé celui
qui a arrêté le feu ah oui dans l'esprit
qui est juste pour qu'il puisse découler
tranquillement c'est ça la sidr cette
manière décoller totalement scandaleuse
un chien le dr dang gueule tu te
retrouves un moyen de l'arrêter
bien sûr j'arrête les avions comme ça
vous avez à kerry le plugin google os
oui oh j'aime là on est vraiment spider
man mon gars attendez on va viser
l'avion à on peut décoller nous aussi ou
d'économistes fait approprié à les
battre à sa fin sa part met en position
une opposition que pour aller sur cet
album nul qu'on l'a on là je deviens tu
ouvres aide
ne paniquez pas c'est une première fois
en tant que policier et en tongs policy
bien nul en plus c'est un mec qui est un
mec tu veux aller là où on va l'attendre
là bas croyez moi c'est un très bon plan
vous faites confiance ou pas mais vous
n'êtes pas trop choix en tout cas je
remercie vraiment voleurs de s'échapper
mais de tourner en rond au-dessus de la
ville avec son avion c'est très aimable
je pète un câble je pète un câble non je
ne raterai pas mon gars à bata si tu
dois je me sens porté sous ma valeur je
vais pas vraiment pour faire quoi
oh la la cité à celle la plus stylée le
tout les films d'action du woodrow unis
rich iott mission impossible
on aura la médaille du meilleur
policiers et du plu je loue aussi
peut-être ces programmes très fort
probablement oui on a un trou d'air pas
du tout mais on y va on va dire que oui
et là je fais quoi faut que détruit sa
des lycées ça mais c'est super dangereux
mais je vais mourir dans l'histoire va
détruire lui plutôt [ __ ] un endroit
qu'il a prévu une certaine hauteur de
copies de comme s'ils ont la banane ne
rentrait pas il doit changer de coupe
premiers mois il préféré démissionner
que de changer de coupe cet homme non
oui l'avion tous mais plus l'avion nec
et là bas j'ai trouvé mais je peux plus
la voir ces morts mais je fais comment
mais c'est pas là pour ça doit tout ça
[ __ ] de oisemont petit avion à illéla
regardez c'est trop tard je suis trop
loin
icloud at any more mais j'ai perdu et je
fais comment faut que je recommence
bah oui parce que la regarder à marquer
non tu ne peux pas donc je peux patiner
mon [ __ ] de truc dont je dois faire
start excite
j'en ai marre de toi tshongo je veux te
défoncer non non non mais non mais non
tu faisais à la grille ndi d'escaladé et
là il vient pas je me fais taper en
boucle non ça c'est quoi ce jeu buggé
quoi son agent troisième mais bordel
mais non non tu te plais thurgoviens
l'autre côté de la grille sont mignons
mon petit chou goût mignon et minutes
plus tard à ce que ça fait du bien de
requêtes la bombe ou du coup vous n'avez
pas vu la souffrance la douleur
engendrée par je suis pas un
présentateur taylor pourquoi je parle
comme ces personnes-là bon je pète un
câble
ç'a marché en random comme ça elle va s
il estime à 600 dollars oui cette
souffrance là bas c'est un millième de
ce que j'ai dû endurer ça fait du bien
allez tu vas sur lui un retour dans les
nuages est là je ne tombe pas de ce
[ __ ] d'avion je mettrai le temps qu'il
faudra mais je finirai ce je m'entendais
je finirai ce jeu j'ai dit que je ferai
pas cette erreur je suis désolé comment
jusqu'à sage avec ma main comme ça où on
y est c'est la deuxième la deuxième ce
qui verse qu'on va pas du tout mourir
avec cet homme est bon de merde pas de
panique où j'ai pas dit que j'avoue je
suis mieux monter
pas du tout un agent de police lui voilà
aidez moi j'ai fait particulier la
police et j'ai besoin de renforts j'en
ai marre de ce jeu de ce je pensais pas
qu'elle développeurs de ce jeu mais sur
cette partie là il a déconné comme sur
toutes les spots halal attention pas de
oui oh oh c'était bon oh c'était
incroyable j'ai jamais eu à 1
ainsi bon feeling yes [ __ ] de voleurs
vous n'aurez jamais d'un gars c'est une
blague
on n'a pas le temps dans un caddie à
fuser nickel alors il ya eu un problème
parce que j'ai pas tellement court mais
s'était pas sur tout le monde était sur
un avion qui se crashe et le monde était
dans un caddie à fuser alwil texture
mois date fois que c'est beau ça non
l'attrapera et ce jour là je ferai la
danse du ventre
il est où les jours cela tient watts et
je sais que ça ce qui se passe qu'est ce
qui se passe
est-ce qu'on l'avait est-ce qu'on a
attrapé ce volet remet à la fois
manning dingo
est ce que ça vient de recommencer là je
peux plus je peux lui bon vous pardonner
voilà je vous paie une petite danse du
ventre
je ne sais pas la faire bientôt web
manager cette fois ne s'est pas de vidéo
j'aurais jamais aux tonga l'aller j'ai
joué une heure je suis sûr que
normalement tous fait en 15 minutes
grand max bon j'espère quand même ça
vous a plus ces cas n'hésitez pas aimé
la vidéo va devenir policier mais
attention point police est normal un
policier qui glisse sur le sol et qui
s'accrochent aux avions quand vous leur
part en avion mythique as these lice
avec ses bras mais savoir garder un tour
de vis dans une nouvelle vidéo sur un
jeu moins buggée au jeu rage le moins
c'est promis toit de mon b